>>Chris: Oftentimes we have private
think time before we share our visual
models in math, Matthew.
>>Narrator: Chris Opitz
is a master teacher
at Bowman Elementary
School in Anchorage, Alaska.
He views math as a social
activity, and believes taking time
to impart the skills required
for cooperative learning can lead
to calmer classrooms and
more rigorous studies.
>>Chris: Why is private think
time important before we have
our discussions?
Sadie, what are you thinking?
>>Narrator: This fifth grade math
class was recorded during the first
month of the school year.
>>Chris: At the beginning of
the year, we establish a set
of working agreements that I provide
four categories, I provided speaking,
listening, thinking and
behavior, and that's really,
social emotional learning.
Then we did an exercise
where the kids thought about,
and kind of imagined a great
classroom, like, the best place
where they could possibly be
learning, and what would that look
like in each of those categories?
And so we took all of those ideas
and we developed what's
called our working agreement.
And then kids look at that
consistently and set goals from that,
and then they rate themselves.
You know, today I did a great job,
and they provide an explanation
and evidence of their rating
in terms of those goals.
Also we do a lot of discussion,
and that's another area.
Kids did the same thing,
they worked together,
and thought of what a
great discussion is.
It wasn't kids raising their hands,
it was kids bouncing
ideas off each other.
I personally believe, when kids
have some say in making those rules
and those routines, and
those working agreements,
they're going to own them more.
>>So I'm going to give
you your first model.
We're probably going to go around
and do a fish bowl, where we stand
around the outside, and we're
going to watch and really think
about what a good discussion looks
like, how we talk and how we listen,
how we ask questions,
all of those good things
that you guys do very, very well.
So here's your first model.
Please honor the private think time.
Want me to read it with you?
Mike has eight dollars, Kelly
has twice as much as Mike.
Do you know what that
word twice as much means?
Hey, Riley, could you and Laura
work together as a team on this one?
Would that be okay with you?
>>Riley: Sure.
>>Chris: Okay.
>>Riley: So Mike has eight
dollars, is this Mike?
>>Laura: Yeah.
>>Chris: In any classroom,
anywhere you go,
you're going to have an incredibly
broad range of kids, socially,
academically, all across
the spectrum,
and so how does a single person,
as a teacher, as a manager, teach,
you know, 20 to 30 kids
in a single classroom,
when that ability range is so wide?
I personally believe that the
social skills and more importantly,
students building social skills
to help them work together,
to talk about math, to
explain their thinking,
to offer help when another student is
struggling, and just as importantly,
for that child to be
able to accept help.
That's a really difficult
part of that equation.
All of those skills are part of the
social arena that we're working in,
and without them, I don't know
how you could teach a classroom
with such a broad range of abilities.
>>Riley: How do you
want to make this model?
>>Chris: Kids' ideas matter.
>>Thank you for sharing your idea.
>>When we pay attention to their
ideas, not necessarily saying,
that's a good idea,
or that's a bad idea,
but we say, thank you for your idea.
They're more willing to share it,
they probably care a little bit more,
it probably feels a little
bit safer to share that idea,
because no matter what I say or
try to push, unless kids own it,
it's not going to matter.
>>I took your ideas
about discussions,
what makes a really great discussion,
and I wrote them on
the board for today.
And so when we go to fish bowl, we're
going to choose a team like we do.
We're going to go around and we're
going to make these observations,
and your job as an audience, is
to listen very closely to see
if every voice is heard
at that table.
I want you to listen for
thoughtful questions,
and look for this evidence.
You ready?
Okay, remember, give them space.
Give them space, and
if you're in front,
what can you do to let everybody see?
Audience, our voices are off, we're
just going to look for evidence
of a really great discussion,
and then we're going
to talk about that afterwards.
>>I began using the fish bowl,
having kids really closely
observe other kids in discussion,
identifying particular types of
language, ways to ask questions,
how to use manners when
disagreeing, how to choose--
as simply as how to
choose who speaks first.
>>Student: I'll start.
>>Chris: In a fifth and sixth grade
classroom, we wouldn't expect that,
but boy, it can derail
a classroom instantly,
if they don't have those basic skills
and once that foundation is built,
then the academics can be
so much more thoughtful,
so much more intense, and
that's what we're shooting for.
>>Student: So Mike started with
eight, Kelly had twice as much
as Mike, and Joe had
half as much as Kelly.
>>Chris: Every teacher out there has
probably said, at some point in time,
turn to your neighbor
and talk about this idea.
Look at your teammates
>>Student: Actually, I'm not quite
getting, why did you do those shapes?
>>Student: Because it looked cool.
>>Chris: And really watch, and if
they are talking about the topic
that you've asked them to talk
about, if they're actually listening
to each other, and using that
language and those social skills,
then all of a sudden,
you have an environment
where 30 kids are all
learning at the same time.
>>Student: And how
would you get three,
even if you did the half of eight?
That's four.
>>Student: Is that right?
>>Student: I don't
know how I got three.
>>Chris: It's not going to happen
at the beginning of the year,
but in my opinion, the
efficiencies that you'll gain later,
by far outweigh the time you spend at
the beginning, teaching those basics.
>>Caleigh, I was standing behind
you, and I kept hearing a lot
of questions coming your way.
How did that make you feel?
>>Caleigh: I don't know.
>>Chris: I mean, sometimes when
people ask me a lot of questions fast
in a row, I get kind of nervous.
Do you know what I
mean, and I can't--
my thoughts, I kind of
lose my own thinking.
Does that happen to anybody else,
when somebody says, Hey, Riley, hey,
Riley, did you-- what's the answer?
But do you know what I mean?
>>Riley: Yeah.
>>Chris: Yeah.
And you get a little
nervous but that's all right,
that's part of our learning.
And so I want you to feel
comfortable with that.
That's okay to feel that way.
>>Right now, we're going to have--
the observers are going to discuss
a little bit and make some comments.
Audience, what are some
things that you noticed, okay?
>>Riley: I kind of have a comment,
but I think next time, Braden,
because maybe you should spread it
out, because when you first had,
like the red right there, and
then the green right there,
it kind of looked like
it was just 32.
>>Braden: Well, I was thinking
of it, from, like, a side view,
so if you're like down--
but I mean, if--
still, you can kind of
somewhat see from my angle.
>>Chris: Say we provide
a math problem.
Many students can find
the answer very quickly,
but can they explain the process
that was happening in their mind?
Can they explain it to somebody
that doesn't understand it?
You take a really gifted kid, for
example, and you have them try
to explain a multiplication
problem, a very basic one.
They know the answer like that.
And try having them
explain it to somebody
that it doesn't come so quickly to.
It's an amazing activity to watch, to
see them think through the process,
oh, well I know that three times
four is three groups of four,
or four groups of three,
and here's how I see it,
and here's what it
looks like visually,
and that's how I get to this answer.
It's an entirely different skill to
be in tune with your own thinking,
and so, in order to do
that in the classroom,
those social skills
need to be in place.
>>Okay, for closing today, you're
going to go to your math journals,
and you're going to write--
>>By spending some time
developing these routines,
and helping kids learn
social and emotional skills,
where they can manage themselves
and their interactions with others,
the classroom will be
a better place to be,
and the academics will also be--
have the opportunity to be
more rigorous, and thoughtful.
And I've seen it work
in my classroom,
and I believe it can
work in other classrooms.
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.